c'était un symbole du monde de la
culture de la mode à la française
militant engagé dans la lutte contre le
sida et la cause lgbt
pierre bergé est décédé ce vendredi
matin à l'âge de 86 ans l'ex compagnon
d'yves saint laurent a été connue des
yvelinois il était le président du
conseil d'administration de la maison
emile-zola à situer à médan sa
disparition est évidemment un choc pour
de nombreux acteurs locaux écouter deux
réactions recueillies au téléphone ce
vendredi pierre bergé était un acteur
qui étaient vraiment engagés dans la
solidarité dans les luttes contre les
discriminations et effectivement il va
un des tableaux sont puisque ben nous on
ne connaissait bien il a soutenu à
chaque prévention pendant des années on
a même eu notre première unité mobile de
dépistage du dépistage du sida qui était
donc financé par sa fondation
c'est un mécène un ami des artistes
voilà ça a été un compagnon de route
aussi de la gauche française il faut
reconnaître cela est lui resté fidèle
mais plus encore c'est un symbole je
crois pour tous les progressistes à vis
d'une société plus tolérante et plus
solidaire